Instagram stories I'm playing with it
I'm making my first story right now to
wait and see I think it's important
unexpected but exciting and scream sorry
sook Instagram stories what he thinks
the biggest thing I can bring to them I
would say personal hell thank you so
much of Bella thanks your market your
personal brand I would say how you
communicate with your people right so
even if I go like at least that's how I
started my paper it's such a I love when
it's a smaller room toward is much cute
like I want to give them I can
pontificate forever
but giving a direct answer is always you
know inevitably in a size like this Matt
guys question is what 80 percent are
thinking as well you really we heard
when you hear insurance positive or
negative right are such I can everything
is you're laying out to us what change
that
now that is what Lester's whatever the
biggest influence for position in
America is the mothership on 6th ed
remember he's a 1020 too much change
America's perception of you character
all right take care woman yeah I gotta
go see you later
take care guys Sam I think we got real
practical with them did the half-hour
and turned into Q&A and that's work
about that person they want a flasher
now I have to go to LA now for another
conference thank you
wait a minute wait a minute Instagram
stories Instagram stories
my thoughts are the same as anytime a
major platform makes an update copies a
feature from somebody else adjust just
what somebody else is doing to wait and
see right like I don't have I don't
actually have many emotions or thoughts
or a fad I'm more curious of watching
people interact with it and see what
happens
so it's early I think it's important
I've mentioned my concern about
Instagram positioning in the marketplace
not too long ago
I actually think instagrams in a weird
horrible position though I don't like
how we're getting squeezed right now
between snapchat and Facebook but
Facebook has its generation and just
snapchat eating up too much of what it's
red hat and so unexpected but exciting I
think it's a smart fast follow I will
see if it's Plex I think a lot of times
features are our big plays I think when
Instagram did video because mine was out
there in essence really was a big deal
this I'm not so sure snapshots and much
bigger players than vine was at that
point we'll see
makes me discover one funny
hey my man G alright guys this has been
like two years in the making or
something started something there all
right please come
it gives me the best talk here I'm
dropping the best top 2:30
I'll see you that thank you thank you I
you've got some incredible things Thank
You Man and you stay very humble which i
think is so critical
I think so too man man I appreciate that
and it's funny you know went on stage my
ego my ego goes but in real life you
know it's funny you're up on camera on
stage my ego goes but in this my
humility goes yeah you know it's amazing
full of English I think so what the [ __ ]
am i yeah like I know I've done well
there's many other people have done well
like the other thing is I genuinely like
people yeah which is imagination yeah to
cut to the real chase that's the saving
grace like I genuinely like these people
thanks for the invite man I just got in
this morning yeah not like I actually
didn't check your stamp out dude
congrats congrats Congrats that's
[ __ ] insane I can't believe you
couldn't even you guys gave me a little
preview it was only two Wow
hello gang hello gang
is that the Sandman
hi mushi
heíd Wadhwa I love you mushi Breen's
I love you bye mommy love you mommy
so here's my new feature for Instagram
stories I'm gonna give you guys screen
savers once a day my new screensaver is
up next
now let's keep using the functionality
this amazing thing d-roc anyway
message me right now if you're using the
screensaver
what up snapchat would love for you to
go check out my Instagram story I'd love
to get your two cents on it
it's a rim story silk same the same
[ __ ] that loved Instagram 11 months
ago and what like snapchat is [ __ ]
are literally gonna say Instagram
stories or [ __ ] snapchats the best
same characters I hate that changed Iraq
they hate that change I love that change
because it's inevitable
you know I'm playing with it I'm making
my first story right now first of all I
think it's a very well-made product it's
very intuitive even the first four to go
rounds I think that's always important
having intuitive products matters
I think the UI and the UX of where they
put the stories is huge
they're just unmissable so super
intuitive it's a very well-made product
that's important that's number one next
it just comes natural and I usually I
usually do things don't come natural to
me usually so that was actually a good
thing too I'm fascinated by the UI and
UX of the product where the most recent
five or six are the ones that show up
before you start sliding which i think
is going to induce a lot of people to
create often to gamify it to be one of
those things that is always there when
people open up their Instagram so I
think that has the potential to create a
lot of activity early on which is
probably going to be important and three
I would say that anybody that thinks
that this is going to kill snapchat is
completely out of their mind that's an
incredibly no chance statement and I
would also say that uh let's not forget
the instagrams already had success I
think I said this in the video with fast
following vine and doing video and that
pretty much killed mine there's no shot
of killing snapchat but I do think it
there's a shot for people that have been
able to build big audiences on Instagram
and have not yet built big audiences on
snapchat this may create a scenario
where they won't try to create big
audiences on snapchat and that alone is
a win for Instagram yeah it won't kills
it won't it won't it won't kill snap
check of snapchats too big that's all
it's just too big too much too many
people have too many audiences there's
so many people that use it plus there's
a lot of people that won't get it Vince
to Graham a shot here because they think
it's a copycat play and out of the
emotion that'll they go screw that I
mean what this is going to do what
snapchat taught us is there's a place
for content that is not that serious
I think Instagram became like a museum
and snapchat became like your
conversations and I think that what this
is going to do for a lot of Instagram
celebrities content producers media
companies brands is allow them to
produce a lot more
on 10th for snapchat there's a lot of
people on snapchat that are way too
fancy and only post one or two things
and they have to be perfect this is
going to give them that ability to not
be as perfect which will make them
create more all these things start off
as something it could have any niche
that the next big social network is
going to start out with some niche some
feature build critical mass and then
just become a content platform with
every option of every way to do it got
it
it's one of the reasons I'm surprised
that snapchat has not started doing live
yet I just think it's inevitable
eventually snackable content evergreen
content and live content will be the
cost of entry to be a modern day massive
social network boom let's call it my two
cents on Instagram stories and its
impact on business I think that
Instagram got too fancy like you only
post once a day
yeah it's authentic it's the authentic
version of your like most prized content
of the day yeah did you see you again
brother
Toria hey how are you
how are you my speech it so minute I'm
free to Laura founder of this MoMA
very nice man but the pleasures all
right there I could never stand by the
door and say no two people I'd be like
just sit on the [ __ ] floor like d-roc
you should go outside and get all the
disappointed patrons
thanks for coming 90 minutes it's been
[ __ ] me awesome I'm super pumped and
the thing that I really tried to think
about was okay if we're gonna have such
a distinct different group people coming
from music and art you know
entrepreneurship marketing what I'm
going to do is I'm going to talk about
some themes that I think really bring
the most value across the board and then
I want to open it up I mean I think you
know 95 percent of some room should be
giving a presentation as well so the one
thing I decided to talk about was
attention I think what I've done really
well for the last 20 years of my life is
reverse-engineer attention usually by it
at an under priced attention tension
that was set up you all looked you all
looked you know how hard it is to like
riff for 90 minutes and the thing is as
you know like I think what's interesting
about how I do it I think that was me
actually asking more of you a question I
feel like I constantly have a library of
three hours worth of content
and just like there's always some mix of
it right
you may feel like for everybody yeah
yeah I'm think I'm going to bat I know
at a 95 to 98% of you when you hear the
term social media think of it as
something in the appendix an
afterthought and we're only probably
from 80 to 90 percent of you something
has zero impact on your money the way I
look at moments your platforms very
simply is as gateway drugs to
interpersonal relationships